depuis les témoignages de renvoyer
spéciale de cinq femmes accusant nicolas
hulot de viol et d'agression sexuelle
tout le monde se demande comment
l'ancien ministre de l'écologie at il pu
rester si longtemps couvert en france
des hommes violents toute impunité une
enquête publiée dans paris-match
intitulé le scandale hulot 20 ans
d'omerta révèle les dessous d'une
affaire qui pourrait s'avérer bien plus
sombre cette affaire hulot pourrait bien
avoir des conséquences politiques
beaucoup plus large ces agissements avec
les femmes beaucoup les connaissait en
2006 il aurait même agressé sexuellement
la petite fille de l'ancien président
françois mitterrand pascal stagiaires
photographe à l'époque pascal mitterrand
passe la porte d'une gendarmerie pour
déposer plainte pour viol contre nicolas
hulot et le magazine rapporte aussi que
nicolas hulot aurait instauré un système
de points pour noter ses conquêtes avec
une autre personnalité elle aussi
accusée décemment de viol patrick poivre
d'arvor on parle aussi de cette enquête
préliminaire ouverte pour viol contre
patrick poivre d'arvor l'ancien
présentateur vedette de nouvelles
informations qui ont poussé emmanuel
macron a réagi à intervenir en pleine
polémique demi tout politique nous
n'accepterons jamais une société de
l'opacité ou de la complaisance nous ne
voulons pas non plus d'une société de
l'inquisition alors nouveau témoignage
santé inquiétant de secret gardé retour
sur les révélations de la férule haut
dans paris match
et pour en parler évidemment j'ai notre
avocat roland perez ami de la famille
tmp qui vient régulièrement sur ce
plateau et fatima benomar
militants féministes et chroniqueuse
dans les stades midi sur rmc et puis
vous venez vous aussi vous êtes ami de
la famille aussi régulièrement dans tpm
paix qu'est ce que vous pensez de fatima
de ce qu'on a pu lire aujourd'hui dans
ce dossier de paris match je trouve ça
assez honnête par ailleurs même les
commentaires sur les états d'âme de
nicolas hulot nous justement les
féministes on veut surtout pas tomber
dans le discours pour te dire que les
hommes qui agressent et qu'ils violent
des femmes seraient des monstres parce
que du coup on les extériorise de la
société et on ne se dit pas que c'est la
société qui est un problème mais moi ce
qui me touche c'est encore une fois
comment il reste du travail à faire pour
préciser de quoi on parle c'est à dire
que même la fille de cette ministre qui
dit avoir été enfermée avec nicolas
hulot qui a dû courir avec un nicolas
hulot qui lui qui lui court après pour
l'agresser sexuellement elle dit mais je
veux pas mettre mon témoignage même
niveau que les autres ce que j'ai vécu
c'est pas très grave par rapport à elle
à partir de quel moment ce n'est pas
grave se retrouver dans un appartement
enfermé deux voir courir pour sauver sa
peau d'une agression c'est que je
reviens justement sur ce que vous disiez
ce témoignage donc de la fille de
l'ancien ministre du gouvernement jospin
elle raconte ce qui s'est déroulé
pendant la campagne présidentielle de
2006 il lui avait donné rendez vous chez
lui dans son appartement parisien elle
ne s'est pas méfié parce que je le
connaissais bien les jouer de ses
enfants traîner par terre voilà ce que
ce qu'elle raconte
et quand les journalistes eux raconte
quand ils essayent de l'embrasser elle
le repousse il la poursuit autour du
canapé elle veut s'enfuir mais la porte
est fermée à clé elle crie tambourine
contre le battant elle finit par réussir
à s'échapper et se retrouve pieds nus
dans la rue mais hors du piège et enfin
la mère de la présumée victime conclut
elle était furieuse elle l'a raconté
ensuite en le traitant de pauvre type il
avait osé lui dire qu'à lui on ne disait
pas non et donc effectivement elle dit
je ne veux pas que ce témoignage là soit
au même niveau que les autres qui vous
vous dites non alors que c'est déjà très
très grave de se retrouver dans cette
situation à n'importe quelles femmes ou
jeunes filles qui s'y retrouverait
l'assimilent à une agression une
situation de danger dont il faut se
battre pour s'extirper
oui non - pardon mais je comprends pas
l'utilité de ce papier il ya marqué
enquête sur ce qu'ils savaient mais ce
qui savait quoi que c'était un dragueur
lourd qu'il aime bien les femmes books
et d'un violeur pas ce que ça veut pas
du tout dire la même chose il ya autre
chose qui me gêne c'est que ce papier en
fait il dit que nicolas hulot a été
protégé par les puissants qu il aurait
été protégé par tout un système mais
ceux mêmes qui accusent ce système était
au courant donc ça veut dire quoi que
tout le monde est coupable le système
est coupable et puissants sont coupables
c'est ce qu'ils savaient était coupable
non pour moi s'il ya un coupable si les
faits sont avérés c'est nicolas hulot il
faut arrêter d'accuser tout pour moi ce
genre de papier ne sert à rien à part se
faire mousser pour autant pour autant
est-ce qu'on
démonte démonte démonter un système qui
existait qui est un système qui protège
ton grand père tête parce que tout le
monde bien que tout le monde dit alors
la cause déplore par exemple le parti
les verts on se dit bon on va se taire
parce que la cause est plus importante
et pression si on dit que c'est pas
forcément peut-être un type très bien et
bien la cause écologique elle va en
subir les conséquences on peut aussi
dire ça non il faut s'intéresser sur à
quoi sert le on le savait tous et moi je
pense que la dernière
katinan justin sachant pas qui est un
drame je termine c'est un drame qui
survient je suis désolé il ya des gens
qui par ego aime bien se faire mousser
dire oui moi aussi j'étais au courant et
ses sites étaient au courant pourquoi tu
l'a pas dit c'est bien de dire qui est
un sommet m qui protégeait nicolas hulot
mais pourquoi ces gens là eux-mêmes ou
l'ont pas dit ce qui nous intéresse ce
n'est pas de faire des accusations
individuel ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de comprendre la structure qu'est ce qui
permet l'omerta et toutes les femmes qui
ont témoigné dans enquêtes spéciales le
dise personne ne nous aurait cru ou
alors ce sont des comportements qui
était normalisé par exemple claire
nouvian un moment dans le documentaire
elle dit bon on savait qu'ils
consommaient beaucoup de femmes
jusqu'ici on n'est pas dans l'interdît
non et pourtant avant elle précise qu on
lui a dit protège toi si tu es dans ta
cabine fermée là justement à faire d'un
dragueur juste quelqu'un qui voit il ya
des rapports consentis il n'y a pas
besoin de s'enfermer donc c'est dans
cette ambiguïté que l'on daigne parce
qu'un système de violences sexuelles il
s'inscrit à dos dans un système général
de dédramatisation des violences
justement pour revenir là-dessus
guillaume il y avait également le
témoignage de la militante écologiste
pauline lavaud qui explique avoir été
écarté en juin 2011 de la campagne des
verts parce qu elle je la cite un excité
trop le candidat nicolas hulot elle
l'avait d'ailleurs sorti en vidéo donc
c'est intéressant on va regarder cette
vidéo et on en reparlera ce que c'est là
c'est intéressant elle avait exprimé
elle l'avait fait en fonction et pour
lcn qu'on a écarté il m'a regardée
j'avais fait un déplacement avec lui
le soir de ce déplacement je ne sais pas
comment il avait eu mon numéro il
m'avait appelé tard vers 23 heures suite
à ça il m'avait envoyé un sms pour me
souhaiter bonne nuit donc là j'avais
compris que ce n'était pas un appel
professionnels clairement et quelques
jours après cet échange une personne de
son équipe est venue me voir
spontanément pour me dire que j'allais
pas pouvoir faire partie de l'équipe de
campagne parce que j'ai quitté trop le
candidat y avait une sorte de système
autour de lui qui mettait en place
une sorte de stratégie pour écarter
toutes les personnes qui potentiellement
pourrait
être source de problème le problème
étant qu'il aurait pu les agresser alors
évidemment on rappelle un présent que
son innocence a rappelé le président
guillou je suis pas déconnectée parce
que pour le coup moi on était au
téléphone valérie aussi je pense que
vient d'arrêter moi honnêtement c'est
c'est vrai omerta parce que vraiment sur
ce personnage là je n'ai moi jamais
entendu aucun bruit et pour le coup on
est d'accord devrait arrêter je
n'étais pas non mais non je veux dire
que quand on quand on parle d'omerta
pour son cas à lui il ya d'autres
personnes vont participer da dont on ne
rompt savait très bien qu'il était un
peu voilà un an auparavant un peu plus
chaud bouillant mais lui honnêtement
dans l'ain et il croit moi l'omerta et
et hoda parce que vraiment
c'est pas vrai mais c'est compréhensible
je le redis une nouvelle fois il ya dix
ans pendant une conversation entre amis
ou un dîner mondain tu exprimé en disant
attention nicolas n'est pas parfait ni
sur le plan professionnel parce qu'ils
cassent le matériel qu'on lui donne ni
sur le plan sentimental parce qu'il ya
quand même des comportements de blizzard
on te réponde et systématiquement tu es
la seule à dire ça tu casses tube tu
casses une image dans les médias vous
savez c'est tout et le public n'avait
pas envie d'entendre parce qu'on ne met
jamais en cause le public mais le public
ne va pas mettre rendez-vous l'homme
n'était pas prêt à entendre quoi que ce
soit sur nicolas
desrochers les magazines et les proches
évidemment réfute le fait qu'ils d'avoir
été au courant et de ne pas avoir agi
parce qu'effectivement ça aurait pu eux
aussi tombés sous le coup de la loi
ainsi le nom oui un crime non
dénonciation de crime et c'est le cas
par exemple de jean paul besset qui est
un ancien député écologiste européen
écologiste et proche de nicolas hulot
qui dit je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas eu
de suspicion sur ses comportements il ya
toujours eu des choses de ce point de
vue là mais je n'ai jamais eu
connaissance ou constaté de déviance
prédatrice ni de violence si j'avais été
témoin j'aurais couper toute relation
alors juste je voudrais revenir sur
quelque chose il n'y a pas eu de il ne
dit pas qu'il n'y a pas eu de suspicion
sur ses comportements c'est à dire qu'à
chaque fois on nous dit oui on savait
mais bon c'était un dragueur s'est il
était un peu lourd il y avait des
suspicions mais on nous a jamais dit que
est-ce que ce vocabulaire là il va
peut-être un petit peu changé pas dit je
pense que selon à qui on s'adresse on
voit bien on parle c'est à dire qu'en
général on va dire ça peut-être dans un
discours public par contre aux femmes on
va leur dire attention ne te retrouves
pas seul avec lui ça veut bien dire
qu'on pressent par derrière que nous ne
parlons pas de situation des libération
sexuelle où tout le monde prenait
plaisir et tout le monde est égaux donc
je pense qu'on comprend très bien de
quoi on parle depuis dragueur lourd
c'est à dire que c'est ça ou on est dans
un continuum des violences sexuelles
c'est à dire qu'un dragor je sais ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui va essayer de
séduire une personne et puis si elle
voit que ça accroche et ben ça continue
un tour l'ours en général on en parle
entre 9 c'est un mec qui quand il a
compris et quand on lui a envoyé un
signal clair qu'il n'y a pas moyen
insiste et ça ça a des répercussions sur
nous les femmes c'est à dire que si on
est dans une soirée on va aller demander
un pote d'aller le gérer on va commencer
à l'esquivé on va demander un pote de
nous raccompagne à l'origine conditionné
dans le travail on va essayer de lui en
fait c'est nous qui prenons des
dispositions pour ne pas nous retrouver
dans dans le périmètre un danger avec
quelqu'un qui a une réputation de
dragueur lourd alors j'ai une question
parce que on en a parlé avec fiona parce
qu'on on évoquer cet article pendant
dans la loge et dans l'article plus il
ya plusieurs personnes qui se sont
souvenu d'un jeu que patrick poivre
d'arvor avait instauré avec nicolas
hulot qui est un système de points pour
chaque femme conquise dans le public
tant pour une serveuse temps pour une
hôtesse de l'air est l'ami de ppda dont
il est question cette hulot ont confirmé
plusieurs sources d'après donc paris
match alors là numériquement fiona me
dis ouais enfin des copains qui sortent
avec des filles qui donne des points aux
filles sait on en connaît tous et c'est
pas très grave c'est sa fille avait fait
est là où on se rejoignait valérie sais
comment c'est la seule gravité
aujourd'hui dans cette histoire c'est le
consentement en fait c'est juste qu'à
partir du moment où de une femme et un
homme ou deux hommes ou deux femmes
couchent ensemble si les deux sont
consentants il n'y a pas de problème
après kiss note qui snobe pas oui c'est
lourd oui c'est embêtant mais voilà s'il
n'y a rien de grave hélas juste je suis
pas d'accord et vous c'est que un
dragueur lourd c'est quoi en fait c'est
vous qui jauge est en fait vous vous et
moi on va pas jauger la lourdeur de la
même manière l'homme en face alors je
sais qu'il y en a qui abusent mais
l'homme en face quand est ce qui va se
dire voilà je suis trop lourd ou là je
pourrai ce que j'en serai un
exemple moi quand je drague quelqu'un ou
que je suis intéressé par quelqu'un je
deviens bac +10 en signe de consentement
c'est dire qu'à ce moment là mais moi je
veux dire tous mes neurones sont
connectés pour essayer de percevoir une
réciprocité pour la très simple raison
que je n'ai pas envie de prendre un
râteau mais est-ce que vous pensez que
tout le monde réagit comme vous c'est ça
que vous vous dire c'est que vous avez
une bonne manière de chercher sa
localisation féminine et masculine qui
ne se construisent pas de la même
manière en fait et quand vous dites
qu'il ya des choses qui sont interdites
par la loi ce je suis d'accord avec toi
et on est les premières à faire de la
prévention tout à l'heure je vais me
laisser le métier voilà qui montre qu
est ce que c'est que de harcèlement
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une agression
mais tout ça vit dans un continuum de
dénigrement et du mépris pour les femmes
par exemple quelque chose qui n'est pas
interdite quand vous regardez le film
les bronzés il ya un moment deux
protagonistes et les personnages et
thierry lhermitte et je crois de
christian clavier qui s'amenait à teneur
et les femmes avec qui ils couchent
n'importe quelle femme qui voit ça
comprend que il s'agit d'un comportement
misogyne de minoration des femmes le il
dit ce qu'il y notait selon leur statut
si c'était une soeur v 6 d une hôtesse
il n'y a pas besoin de ce soit interdit
par la loi pour qu'on se pose la
question est-ce que ça on veut qu'on
continue pour ressentent les femmes
quand elles apprennent à posteriori que
le mec avec lesquels on est pauvre en
couches et c'était un rituel juste je
suis autant revenir à la sphère hulot et
allaoui london de paris match mais m
roland perez merci encore d'être avec
nous qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
couverture médiatique de la faire parce
que ça va jouer en sa faveur est ce que
ça va plutôt joué contre parce que là on
a un élément nouveau qu'on entendait
plus quand on n'entendait pas s'est il
ne se sent pas bien il doit sont ces
faits sont prescrits et on est en train
d'abattre un homme il s'est retiré en
bretagne il et il est malheureux alors
ce qui est certain alors moi je parle
pas de nicolas hulot lui-même même si
aujourd'hui ils illustrent cette triste
affaire je parle pas évidemment de
toutes les victimes et je suis pas
l'avocat de nicolas hulot ce que je sais
simplement c'est que on est aujourd'hui
partagé nos juristes on est très
partagée sur à la fois les médias la
menace les tabloïds qui peuvent être un
déclencheur on l'a vu avec l'émission
enquête
en voyage l'ours est en alerte sans
risque envoyé spécial on l'a vu avec
cette émission elle a déclenché
véritablement aujourd'hui des poursuites
contre nicolas hulot donc on se dit
c'est bien parce que finalement des
victimes on peut être entendu et
finalement et puis après on se dit que
si ces mêmes médias ces tabloïds ces
réseaux sociaux sont croyais heures
c'est un endroit la vie d'un homme vous
savez que mitterrand à l'époque des
suicides de son premier ministre avait
dit on on jette son livre au loup aux
chiens l'honneur d'un homme et bien
c'est ça aussi c'est à dire que la loi
vous dis il faut qu'il y ait un procès
issa ben ça veut dire pour un procès
équitable
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on entende
tout le monde qu'on entende
effectivement ces personnes qui avaient
alors après il ya ce phénomène
psychologique qui à retardement qui fait
que les gens qui font que les personnes
est victime attendre 10 ans 15 ans pour
pour se plaindre mais ce sont des
personnes qui avaient les moyens d'aller
à la justice à l'époque qu'il n'y ont
pas été il ya aujourd'hui cette
prescription dans les médias il a fait
le problème des plaintes contre l'ami de
chirac c'est ce que bâle avait justement
justement vous me permettez de faire
cette transition puisqu'on va notamment
parce que le dossier s'intéresse aussi
au fait qu'ils ont il a été couvert sur
tout ça où ils auraient été couverts ce
qu'on rappelle encore on est obtenue à
parler de la présomption d'innocence de
nicolas hulot mais plusieurs ont on les
sent tous embarrassé évidemment à droite
comme à gauche parce qu'il a été de tous
elle est de tous les bords nicolas hulot
je veux qu'on voit 101 en quelques
instants ce matin sur apolline le matin
sur nbc alice coffin qui a passé un coup
de gueule sur cette affaire et notamment
sur la réaction d' emmanuel macron en
conseil des ministres regardez
après cette enquête diffusée sur envoyée
spéciale en prime time sur le service
public qui je crois a ému des millions
de personnes en france et notre
président parle d'inquisition c'est une
forme de complaisance pour le coup c'est
surtout renvoyé un message à l'ensemble
des femmes de ce pays qu'elles sont
vulnérables dans ce pays qu'elles sont
exposées cas personne à la tête de
l'état pour les protéger et au contraire
que ce que fait le président de la
république qu'il dénonce celle les
militantes féministes notamment qui font
le travail que lui ne fait pas et alors
on a également françois bayrou ce matin
qui est lui en gros nous explique que
quand on est au gouvernement au soutien
ses collègues quoi regarde c'est grave
alors évidemment vous êtes dans un
gouvernement ya des effets de solidarité
qui peuvent parfois conduire à des
prises de position ou à des imprudences
tout ça c'était las la vie de tous les
jours peut-être y at-il un problème de
précipitations quand les gouvernements
se forme on est dans une ambiance ce
effervescente quelle ambiance de
l'alternance où tout le monde veut
monter dans le train et le train envie
de partir il ya des vérifications et ce
n'est pas les vérifications
sérieuses dont on devrait avoir besoin
alors que ya trois jours à 90 qu'il est
ce qu'il a dit ça est ce que vous vous
le comprenez guillon je ne comprends pas
ce qu'il n'est pas en train de dire oui
je savais que nicolas hulot était un
violeur malgré ton cours même si non ils
sont vos repas faut arrêter le cours et
non mais non il a dit oui j'étais au
courant que c'était un violeur il a dit
le coût
des problèmes qu'on découvre guillaume
en ce moment et l'arc de paris se
montrait bien c'est qu'il ya un système
organisé pour protéger d'accord ce soit
au sein du gouvernement ou dans la
mouvance des verts de l'écologie où il
ya eu plein d'affaires et où des femmes
été agressé et et pour des intérêts
particuliers certains ne parlait pas
j'ai donc ce système de protection il
doit sauter guijin
spécialement c'est le cas évidemment
qu'il faut le dénoncer mais un peu de
subtilité s'il te plaît différence entre
être au courant que c'est un homme à
femmes puisque connacht maladie c'est
autorisé et c'est un violeur il n'a pas
dit françois la vie en chasse qui
avaient été déposées pour viale d'accord
mais très bien est ce qu'il a dit a vite
j'y suis toujours dit les noms
arrêtez-moi plein qui d'abord m on voit
bien dans envoyé spécial que les filles
et les jeunes femmes ne parle pas parce
qu'elles sont souvent prises parce
qu'elles ont peur parce qu'il est connu
parce qu'il est influent et donc ça on
voit bien qu'elles ont besoin de 10 ans
de 15 ans de 20 ans et après ben voilà
c'est ya prescription donc ça je trouve
qu'on se sent bien et moi j'ai trouvé
pardon mais l'article de paris match
très intéressant parce que comme vous
l'avez dit fatima et jyles envoie la
toile d'araignée on voit les petits
arrangements entre amis c'est à dire que
il ya un côté on est clément on est
indulgent on est sous on est aveugle en
est amnésique on prend pour est acquis
auprès d'un ferry qui tous ces
témoignages c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de procès équitables n'y a
pas de contre à dire que toutes ces
folles toutes ces nouvelles instances
telles des tableaux mais ce n'est pas
qu'elles mentent mais on prend pour fait
acquis c'est à dire est ce que c'est à
la presse aujourd'hui d'instruire un
procès c'est la question qu'on connaît
vous estimez vous que la presse est en
train d'instruire un procès où est ce
que la presse simplement est en train de
mettre à jour quelque chose qu'on avait
le titre c'est homer tard c'est à dire
qu'on avait mis sous le tapis est donc
en train de libérer une parole et en
même temps donne la parole aux amis de
nicolas hulot dans tous ses procès
instruisent forcément un charge quand on
n'entend pas la parole de l'autre on
instruit à charge la vie sans gêne dit
allez je remets en cause la parole de
l'autre je dis simplement que dans un
procès équitable on entend les deux
parents n'étaient que
ce qui m'interpelle mais malgré tout
c'est que on a le sentiment que d'un
côté on nous dit tout le monde savait et
de l'autre côté ce qu'on interroge dix
personnes savaient donc
mis en cause paris-match pardon paris
match qui compte parmi les plus grands
journalistes vous pensez vraiment qu'à
paris march qui connaît par coeur le
système que nous sommes deux dossiers
invraisemblable et savait pas un novice
au coeur des disques de free complète là
dessus donc les automobilistes
il se permet de prendre en marche mais
paris match je suis désolé ce avait
réussi ainsi tout le monde sa mais paris
match j'avais encore plus que tout le
monde dedans mais ça c'est drôle tout le
monde c est ce que c'est pas tout le
monde soupçonnait même temps quand on
soupçonne quelqu'un qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire quoi enfin comment vous
voulez dénoncer quelqu'un vous arriver
autant
je trouve qu'il ya toujours autant de
cynisme c'est à dire que le problème des
gens est de savoir ce que nico l'agglo
d'abord et est l'une des personnes les
plus populaires de france est la
question que se posent les gens surtout
en ce moment c est ce qui nous dérange
nous risquons en a encore besoin mais la
réalité c'est que vous avez quand même
des gens qui ont porté plainte vous avez
quand même une fille qui était violée
qui attend depuis des années qu'il se
passe quelque chose il ne se passe rien
et aujourd'hui on est en train de parler
de plusieurs autres femmes donc on peut
pas faire le truc comme si rien
n'existait et andré ça existe et
heureusement qu'on en parle enfin parce
que sinon on n'aurait jamais parler
quand elle en parle mais grâce à vous
grâce à ces témoignages on sait faire la
justice son travail je rappelle je
m'appelle de marc mathieu orphelin qui
était donc le proche collaborateur de
nicolas hulot qui qui lui a été invité
sur france 5 et qui s'est exprimé parce
que il a été évincé ce n'est plus donc
le porte parole de la campagne de
yannick jadot il a été remplacé regardez
on était nombreux et nombreuses à
regarder ces cinq témoignages terribles
je le redis toute mon estime pour avoir
eu le courage de témoigner face à des
faits qui sont très graves évidemment
que je n'ai jamais couvert de tels
agissements évidemment que je n'ai
jamais été au courant de tels
agissements nicolas hulot et et
séducteur draps guerre on l'a vu faire
des drague lourde vous l'avez jamais été
témoin oui mais jamais je n'ai vu jamais
évidemment ça aurait tout changé de
notre rapport à nicolas il ou non mais
pour mettre un peu tout le monde
d'accord je pense que les cause que
défend de fatima et plein de gens elles
sont extrêmement importantes évidemment
les agressions sexuelles c'est
extrêmement grave le viol c'est
extrêmement grave maintenant ce qui me
gêne dans le traitement médiatique c'est
qu'on mélange tout je reprends
l'anecdote avec ppda où il comptait il
mettait des points pour les filles on
connaît aussi à plein de femmes qui font
des tableaux et meubles les performances
exilés de leur maman donc il faut pas
tout mélanger là on est dans l'anecdote
de presse people et je trouve au
contraire ça décrédibilise les
témoignages qui sont extrêmement graves
ou d'y aller de son petit commentaire
tout le monde y va de son petit
commentaire avec des oui bah moi aussi
j'ai mais il m'a embrassé une fois mais
quel rapport il faut pas tout mélanger
là on est dans un traitement de presse
people concrètement fatima comment on
fait pour éviter ce tribunal médiatique
justement puisque ça pose un problème
quand on dit on savait où tout le monde
savait comment fait on fait un tweet on
convoque élise lucet commença savent
déjà vos londres que nous nos
associations nous accompagnant tous les
jours des femmes dans les commissariats
dans leur dépôt de plainte et s'est mis
tout effectivement été une monstruosité
pourquoi elle a été mieux ce trio cité
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on a réussi
à mettre au centre de l'attention la
question des destins de ces femmes on
est dans un pays où et c'est admis au
plus haut niveau de l'état il n'y a que
10 % des violeurs qui sont condamnés
quand il ya un procès c'est à dire que
on part du principe du côté de la
justice que 90% des femmes qui portent
plainte mantes et ça ce n'est pas normal
ou va pas dans le
ciel que cette femme ans tu vas d'accord
en tout cas pas chez fernand volant
volant simplement on s'aperçoit le juge
d'instruction qui a l'a fait rentrer les
mains n'a pas les preuves hélas au
matériel maintenance et saas et attendez
donc s'agir également résultat est que
le doute le 12 mars et le système
juridique doute mais déficit toujours à
celui qui n'en a accusé d'autres doutent
malheureusement il bénéficie à celui qui
est accusé
de condamnation si on allait
lancer pour faire aboutir et on essaye
pas d'ailleurs de décourager les femmes
d'écologie
félicité des progrès vous savez très
bien qu'il ya des consignes passées par
la chancellerie partout pour que les
femmes soient entendues a pour qui les
policiers spécialisés et n'aura bientôt
partout il faut s'en féliciter
et que les témoignages le savez il faut
dire ça je vous assure que nous ce qui
nous inquiète c'est le fossé entre la
communication et les faits par exemple
là j'ai revu ma dame moreno faire le
tour des ondes a reçu ici qu'on aime
beaucoup pensent que les autres c'était
là féminin milliards sur la table ce qui
est un énorme et là une autre elle est
exonérée s'investissent un ravin il a
une enquête et les amis ont nicolas
gillet